just when it comes to families like you
do have to give up stuff you probably
aren't going to be happy for many years
yeah not and the Sparks are gonna go
yeah and yeah it's not like but people
women think more about the wedding than
they think about the marriage like what
does married life look like yeah like
yeah and like what percent of women
would get married at a courthouse no
wedding nothing just get married nice
hanky right but that's actually I
thought about since young age I'm like
okay this is what I once where I want to
get married like right but have you have
you thought about what he would want no
no but that's that's the problem
that's the whole problem is like we see
even you you're thinking about the
wedding but there's no marriage yeah
like what what does married life look
like like would you serve your husband
yeah yeah that's that's good that's good
most women are gonna say no to that but
but the the whole idea is like we'll
spend all this time thinking about the
wedding and not the marriage and I think
that's why we have shitty marriages a
great